wir müssen uns durch die büsche an der
frontlinie im osten schlagen mitten in
einem waldstück steht eine der deutschen
panzerhaubitzen gut versteckt es ist das
erste mal dass die ukrainische armee
journalisten mit hier hinnimmt ruslan
ist gerade vor fünf tagen aus
deutschland zurück 36 tage lang wurde er
dort ausgebildet in technik und taktik
der zeitdruck für sie ist enorm denn die
russische armee rückt im osten immer
weiter vor kommt die lieferung der
haubitzen zu spät werden ich glaube es
ist zu spät fiel zu spät warum wir
hätten schon vor dem 24 februar
vorbereitet sein sollen es war bekannt
dass die russen uns angreifen würden sie
werden uns nie in ruhe lassen wir hätten
rechtzeitig darauf vorbereitet sein
sollen
seit wochen kämpfen sie auf verlorenem
posten
einer der soldaten hier dürfen sein
gesicht nicht zeigen führt uns ein video
von ihren einsätzen mit völlig
veralteter technik vor doch jetzt soll
sich alles ändern 12 auf witzen sieben
aus deutschland und fünf aus den
niederlanden sind jetzt in der ukraine
angekommen wo sie eingesetzt werden auch
das streng geheim
egal in welcher armee der welt die
artillerie ist das erste ziel für den
gegner besser ausschalten will denn
diese technik ist für den feind
besonders gefährlich
es gibt nicht viel was wir an diesem
morgen an der frontlinie zeigen dürfen
auch das innere der panzerhaubitze soll
ein geheimnis bleiben darum erzählen sie
hätten die deutschen ausbilder sie
gebeten
ihre seite hat uns gebeten nicht im
inneren zu filmen sie hatten angst dass
informationen über die technik in die
hände der besatzer fallen
welcome to use change haben sie auf die
front geschrieben ein provokanter
willkommensgruß an die russen auch das
ist teil der kriegsführung
so geschaltet ist gustav kressl
militärexperte hat bei der
österreichischen armee eine
offiziersausbildung auch selbst
durchlaufen und das forscher am european
council on foreign relations mit
schwerpunkten der strategie hallo guten
abend herr kressl guten abend diese
panzerhaubitzen können die einen
unterschied machen
für die einheiten in denen sie kämpfen
natürlich ist eine sehr gute panzer pc
mobiles feuer geschützt hat mir sehr
große reichweite natürlichen jetzt zwölf
stück an einer frontlinie die
1200 kilometer lang sind jetzt nichts
das den krieg als ganzes wendet aber
muss sagen diese diese panzerhaubitzen
sind teil eines weiteren hilfspaketes
der alliierten also nicht nur
deutschlands dass die ukraine in die
lage versetzt die nato munition also 150
mm zu verschießen weil die eigene
artillerie munition ausgeht und die
produktion für russische artillerie
kaliber im westen knapp ist oder solches
sicher hinein ein gutes und
wirkungsvolles mittel der unterstützung
die kämpfe konzentrieren sich jetzt zum
teil auf relativ kleine bereiche wenn
man sich jetzt das riesenland ukraine
ankommt person raketen fliegen überall
aber diese stellungskrieg mit panzern
das sind ja eingegrenzte bereiche kann
da wenn man diese haubitzen konzentriert
kann da dann wirklich so was wie eine
rückeroberung von piero donetsk oder
ähnliches möglich sein da überschätzt
man dann diese art von waffe das ist ja
moderne schwere artillerie
sie wird in erster linie dazu eingesetzt
gegnerische artillerie anzugreifen
dadurch dass wir eine sehr hohe
reichweite hat kann man tief hinter der
front stehende russische artillerie- die
ukraine beschießt angreifen da sie eine
sehr genaue warf er ist kann das auch
sehr punktgenau erfolgen und dafür ist
es ist ja auch gut und ausgelegt große
gegenangriffe zum beispiel die
rückeroberung von einer ganzen stadt
dazu brauchst natürlich mehr als nur
artillerie da brauchen dann auch
kampfpanzer da braucht man auch
schützenpanzer und da braucht man auch
im endlager ganzen front ein
kräfteverhältnis dass man dass man das
durchhalten kann das ist für die ukraine
zur zeit schwierig also in einigen front
bereichen haben sie eine überlegenheit
und versuchen die russen zurückzudrängen
aber dort wo russland selber das
schwergewicht setzt da ist die überlegen
reiter russen zahlenmäßig einfach noch
zu groß das haben jetzt eben auch gerade
in diesem leben schon erwähnten und ans
revers oder netz bekannten orten in
deutschland bekannten ort beobachtet
dass die ukrainische seite dann sagt er
wir ziehen uns jetzt zurück und ihn an
das einen taktischen rückzug können sie
uns nicht militärs erklären was ein
taktischer rückzug ist ja das problem
ist die ukrainische seite versucht um
die städte so lange wie möglich zu
kämpfen weil sie in den städten sich mit
der infanterie gut bewegen kann mit
ihren leichten panzer waffen relativ
viel russisches gerät zerstören kann in
der offenen feldschlacht hat sie das
problem dass wir aufgrund der mangel an
kampfpanzern schützenpanzern sich nicht
so leicht bewegen und nicht so leicht
das gefecht führen kann jetzt ist das
problem die serie jetzt ist er nicht
gefallen weil die ortschaft selber und
verteidigt wurde oder weil russland dort
die kräfte zusammen geführt hat um die
ortschaft selber zu stürmen sondern weil
sich im süden der stadt ein anderes
gefecht für die russen entschieden hat
und dann bestand die lage dass diese
stadt entweder eingekesselt wird oder
die ukraine ziehen sich zurück und da
haben sie sich natürlich zurückgezogen
damit sie nicht eingekesselt werden wie
schätzen sie denn insgesamt im moment
die lage an sie sagten da fehlen panzer
zum beispiel aber warum hatte haubitzen
reichen eben dann doch nicht
wie gesagt das ist sie einen
abnutzungskrieg und es ist der krieg
derzeit mit der zwei grössten land
armeen in europa das heißt zwölf sitzen
so gut sie auch sind sind natürlich
nicht das ende der fahnenstange
kampf langsam die lieferungen aus polen
aus tschechien publik gerade mal die
kriegsverluste ausgeglichen die die
ukraine bis jetzt erlitten hat aber um
jetzt wirklich auch wieder zum
gegenschlag sondern größeren gegenschlag
auszuholen reicht das bis jetzt nicht
auch bei den schützenpanzern klafft eine
sehr große lücke bei den ukrainern und
die zu füllen wird schwierig sein die
die amerikaner könnten hier noch größere
waffenlieferungen im herbst bringen
sonst ist der leider recht wenig
angekündigt und das ist das problem der
ukraine sie verfügen zwar über viele
leute sie haben eine mobilmachung
angeordnet sie haben einen sehr hohen
zuspruch an freiwilligen aber diese
kampfbereiten leute männer und frauen
bestehen jetzt als leichte infanterie
das heißt leute mit gewehren leute mit
schmuddel gestützten waffen und im
offenen gelände außerhalb von
ortschaften außerhalb von großen wäldern
können die natürlich in der
beweglichkeit und in der feuerkraft in
der reichweite ihrer feuerkraft mit
einem anzahl oder russischen gepanzerten
verbänden nicht mithalten die natur
denkt außerdem auch noch über ihr
eigenes territorium nach mit der
erhöhung der anzahl von soldaten
soldatinnen für die schnelle
eingreiftruppe
das ist ja erstmal eine enorme zahl von
40.000 auf 300.000 man fragt sich fast
ein bisschen wo kommen die plötzlich
alle her das ist in der tat die frage so
da werden wir in der bewertung noch mal
abwarten müssen wie man sich das auch
vorstellen das hieß ja die schnelle
eingreiftruppe müsse binnen 30 tagen
einsatzbereit sein und das wäre
natürlich für 300.000 man schon eine
steilvorlage das natürlich die response
force größer werden muss das ergibt sich
von selbst die die russischen
streitkräfte den ukrainer einmarschiert
sind in dieser zahl vier mal so groß wie
die ganze nato response force das
problem ist aber auch so schnell so
viele leute einsatzbereit zu machen das
wird sich finanziell und das wird sich
auch von unserer man stärke wir sind ja
auch alten der gesellschaften wir haben
nicht wie im kalten krieg ein ewiges
pool an jungen leuten die alle zur armee
gehen das für sie schwierig darstellen
also da bin ich mal gespannt welche
zeitleisten welchen welche
zusammensetzung man da eigentlich an
denkt und wie man das machen will sagt
experte gustav russell danken vielen
herzlichen dank